My plan had
originally been to enlist in the Army
and then use that to pay for college.
Once I found out about QuestBridge
and the generous financial aid,
the colleges like Yale have,
that sort of changed my plans.
I found out about QuestBridge
actually through a pamphlet in my guidance
counselors office.
I found out about QuestBridge
through my AP English language teacher.
through my older brother.
We both knew that if we were going
to go to college out of state,
we were going to have to find scholarships
and grants to do that.
I was invited to the QuestBridge Conference
here at Yale.
We have a mini college fair
where I really got to meet
a lot of different colleges
and including Yale.
When you hear, you know,
you get to go college for free, you get over
$300,000 worth of scholarships.
Doesn't seem plausible.
I was like,
Is this real, is this legit?
I just went ahead and applied
because it was free.
I decided I would do the National College
Match because it just seemed
like a really good way
for me to showcase who I am.
I focused on QuestBridge
because the profile of students
that they described was exactly who I was.
My test scores, my EFC, my background.
It felt like the perfect fit for me.
I really found that it was nice
to just have it established
through applying through QuestBridge
that I was first generation low income.
I didn't have to talk about that.
All I had to do is talk about myself
and tell my story.
I wasn't trying to fit
into a mold of different
activities or things that weren't
even accessible at my high school.
It allowed me to present my story
and who I am
more than just
what I've done academically.
Knowing that if I matched,
I would have a full financial aid
package was like,
oh, this is really within my reach.
Like, they want people like me.
That's why they're offering this.
Now, me as an admissions officer
on the other side of the application,
it really helps us to read and understand
that story to get a fuller context
of who this applicant is
and how they might fit in on our campus.
When my community
and my family found out that I had matched,
they freaked out.
I didn't expect to get in.
It was just a big celebration moment.
It was preparing for a future
that I never thought
that I was going to be able to have.
The day I was accepted to Yale.
I was like, Wait, no way, This is a prank.
And then I was like, Wait, no, it's not.
I'm running through the house and I'm like, Mom, Mom
you know, look, but
wait a minute,
because I need to check the financial aid
because if I don't have good aid,
I'm not going to be able to go.
And I was like, they're literally like
going to pay for everything.
I had actually never flown by myself
and I was really nervous
to get on a plane
with everything I owned and go to college.
You kind of feel like, okay, I'm
going to be the only one who's
the first person
to go to college in their family,
the only one from a small town, you know,
the only one from from this background.
But when you get here, you see that
there's thousands of other people
with the same experience, you know.
The Quest Scholars Network at Yale
has truly become my family.
I kind of get emotional
just talking about the people
that I've met
through QuestBridge on campus.
I would say the first generation
college student community is very vibrant
and diverse.
Just knowing that everyone has gone
through similar things as me
is comforting.
It is a shared identity that, you know,
hundreds of students come to campus having
and the Quest Scholars Network
is a place for them to share in that,
to come together as a community and sort
of build a home home within Yale.
It's been very valuable in terms
of finding a community
where I feel at home and not out of place.
I think my own preconceived
notions were absolutely inaccurate about,
you know,
I felt like I really found a place that
I fit in at, a sort of home away from home.
I've never felt,
you know, like I didn't belong here.
Sometimes the imposter
syndrome really hits me,
but then I'm like, I got here, too.
Like, in my own way,
it was a different route.
But I got here, and I deserve to be here.
It's going to be hard
because you're doing this by yourself.
But these schools want you.
You deserve to be at Yale.
You can do it.
And you have to have your own cheerleader.
And it is hard, but it's worth it
because Yale is the best thing
that's ever happened to me.